stars from Coronation Street past and
present gathered to pay tribute to a
colleague and friend who had been a
professional performer since the age of
8 the Doughty barmaid she played on
screen for more than 40 years attracted
love and respect just as the woman
herself earned the affection of
colleagues having had a successful stage
and film career before she joined the
street she was the ultimate professional
knew everything there was to know about
showbiz including how to steal a scene
without any words just a perfect look
time to perfection
Betty drivers popularity was reflected
on the manchester streets outside the
church where her funeral took place the
people who worked most closely with
Betty driver say that she was the same
genuine character off screen as she was
on it in the rover's return and perhaps
it was that soft motherly quality that
they've talked about that enabled her to
connect so closely with her audience she
was a great actress he'll start before
Coronation Street and she's a dangerous
lady very kind and I was thinking when
am i hot
91 and still be work and she's been a
great example to the British public
you'd never heard any scandals ever in
the newspaper and so I just think it's a
really nice way to show respect and
celebrate along life we've come from
London with staff at four o'clock this
morning
and the Virgin Trains and we're
absolutely shocked but we feel like we
know this lady because she's been in our
houses for 36 years you know after the
service fellow Coronation Street stars
remembered their friend didn't put on
airs and graces she just
that herself so she could talk to
anybody it talked to you know it didn't
matter what strata society you were from
she would just be herself she didn't put
on a voice or you know or try and talk
down to people and I think that comes
over I think it came over certainly as a
person
Betty driver had a long and successful
career in films and as a big band singer
long before she joined the cast of
Coronation Street but she'll be best
remembered as the hot pot making
earth-mother barmaid whose northern
warmth radiated through millions of
British homes Mike McCarthy Sky News
Manchester